alors ça c'est la voiture de mon mari
elle nous l'assure sa vue est bonne ses
réflexes toujours aussi rapides je
promets d'être sincère elle est tout à
fait apte à la conduite je me sens
maîtresse de mon véhicule s'il neige je
ne sors pas s'il pleut trop aussi mais
rapportait à leur nombre les plus de 75
ans provoquent plus d'accidents que la
moyenne
et quand Pascal Perry aura antenne s'est
engagé à rendre son permis de conduire
qu'il n'a jamais eu d'ailleurs quand il
ne sera plus en état ce qui ne saurait
tarder LCI au plus près sauf que quand
son fils nous montre les portières
enfoncées de la voiture de sa mère là
nous avons un arbre dans la forêt pas
éviter on va dire
et de l'autre côté on a un conduit de
cheminée le levier de vitesse il faut
qu'elle le regarde pour savoir quelle
vitesse elle va passer quand je lui dis
non tu conduiras plus et dis ah mais si
si voilà je lui dis mais je peux pas lui
interdire alors Monique serait-elle dans
le déni j'ai pris un arbre parce que je
pouvais pas l'éviter et puis il faut
raconter une petite anecdote quand même
quand vous travaillez au guichet d'un
cinéma qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas osé
proposer à Catherine Deneuve alors en
fait je travaille dans un cinéma qui
était essentiellement fréquenté par les
personnes
âgées
et qui ont droit à une réduction quand
il pense à la demander et c'est rarement
le cas donc du coup c'est souvent les
employés qui la proposent
qui est arrivé
je pense franchement monsieur Vignal je
pense qu'il faut que vous arrêtiez
d'emmerder les Français les hommes
politiques vous devez rien voir je vous
dis je vous dis vous arrêtez d'emmerder
les Français je sais ça vous fait du mal
d'entendre une chose vraie sincère dans
la macronie
on n'a pas l'habitude de la vérité de la
sincérité moi je vous dis arrêtez
d'emmerder les gens on en peut plus de
vos idées à la con excusez-moi de vous
le dire
jamais
[Musique]
10 minutes d'avancer énorme ça me rend
dingue
tu passes ton nez ça passe tout seul
vous pouvez oui mais vous me posez une
question donc je vous réponds ma réponse
et ben je suis long mais vous savez les
macronistes a fait 5 ans qu'on vous
supporte on vous supporte encore pour 5
ans donc vous allez me supporter 5
secondes moi je vous dis vous arrêtez
d'emmerder les gens autant faire de la
sensibilisation demandez au médecin de
s'en occuper mais sans aucune espèce de
coercition pourquoi pas ça fait 15
minutes que vous êtes là vous payez mais
vous êtes fous ben faut me donner 0
parce
que sinon la demande improbable et
illégale d'un chauffeur de taxi au
youtubeur Michou lors d'un tournage à
Paris l'homme hors champ lui reproche
d'être stationné sur une place réservée
et réclame un dédommagement
je vais m'en aller pour moi c'est plus
simple
une ambiance de rêve partie tes rythmes
endiablés au cœur d'une église un lieu
de prière ou se déroule encore la messe
tous les dimanches transformés en piste
de danse avec consommation d'alcool
autorisé
dans le centre de l’allemagne l’idée
fait l’unanimité parmi ces 700 fêtards
c'est pas juste se retrouver dans une
église mais être ensemble faire la fête
c'est super chouette
c'est une histoire plutôt insolite qui
vient d'être révélée dans la presse une
enseignante accusée sur son élève pour
rappel le twerk est une danse pour le
moins suggestif qui rythme de nombreux
soirées endiablées à l'emplacement de
l'hôtel pas de prêtre mais un DJ et une
grande croix en l'aide a été installée
pour parfaire l'ambiance
au sein de la paroisse s'est
transformations exceptionnelles a fait
l'objet d'un vote le oui l'a emporté
mais d'une courte tête et certains ont
encore du mal à l'accepter
dans cette église les gens essayent
depuis 800 ans de se rapprocher de Dieu
je pense que tout ce qui se déroule dans
cet espace doit servir cette mission et
je ne reconnais rien de tout cela dans
cette trêve une enseignante a donc
réalisé cette danse sur les parties
intimes de son élève de 16 ans en lui
caressant le visage choquez la mère de
l'adolescent immédiatement porté plainte
contre la professeur pour attouchement
sexuel mais de son côté l'enseignante
c'était elle aussi rendu au commissariat
pour dénonciation quel homme mieux alors
la prof doit-elle être lourdement
sanctionnée ça s'appelle thing what the
next en gros chantez quoi qu'il arrive
c'est une sorte de N'oubliez pas les
paroles pour adultes puisque les
candidats doivent pousser la
chansonnette pendant que la demoiselle à
côté et bien les occupent si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire non elle s'est
trompé de micro
c'est ce à quoi vous pensez c'est
exactement ce que vous pensez moi je
regarde pas ce film
ni de série tu fais quoi je me suis mise
à lire
l'art d'aimer
mais l'histoire m'intéresse pas
pardon je suis désolé de perturber la
soirée mais là la planète brûle et tout
le monde regarde ailleurs alors que le
climat c'est comme le théâtre veut dire
même si on y fait pas tous voilà on
n'est pas tous concernés mais on y fait
tous hyper attention on en a besoin non
toi tu stoppes d'accord parce que notre
planète c'est pas comme madame la
ministre de la Culture qu'on peut
changer tous les deux ans j'ai pas
toutes les infos sur le remaniement mais
ce que je veux dire c'est deux planètes
on en a qu'une seule pour toute la vie
nous voilà dans une situation
complètement absurde d'un côté nous
exportons 435 000 tonnes de volailles
par an en Europe et jusqu'au
Moyen-Orient et de l'autre côté nous en
importons 826000 tonnes de plus en plus
depuis le Brésil et la Thaïlande
on aimerait bien comprendre ce paradoxe
on va pas lire le rapport du GIEC je
suis isolé déjà personne c'est ce que ça
veut dire GIEC ça veut dire Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat
[Applaudissements]
la pollution de l'air tu 1200 enfants et
adolescents en Europe chaque année selon
l'Agence Européenne de l'Environnement
l'étude a porté sur une trentaine de
pays face à ces chiffres inquiétants
l'Agence recommande d'améliorer la
qualité de l'air aux abords des écoles
des crèches et des transports en commun
merci
beaucoup vas-y comme ça s'il te plaît
non et par contre
bon si c'est que le cœur d'Alexis
Michalik c'est pas de côté
[Applaudissements]